welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Nick Fury's sneaky sneaking
throughout the MCU has always been
nearly impossible to track this is the
guy who faked his death well enough to
fool two Avengers hid an infinity stone
for over a decade lived in hawkeye's
barn for a bit
and apparently has a scroll duplicate of
himself at his disposal and it is this
insane twist revealed in the spider-man
part from home post credits scene that
has led to one of the most perplexing
mysteries that fans are still wondering
about how long has the Squirrel Talos
been posing as Nick Fury how long is
Nick Fury been in a scroll Space Station
where are Nick Fury shoes last time he
trusted someone he lost a sandal a new
theory has emerged about the exact
timeline of Nick Fury's recent history
in the MCU and his relationship with the
scrolls there is actually enough
evidence to suggest that the Nick Fury
we have been following since 2014 in
Captain America Winter Soldier has in
many key moments actually been a scroll
a deception that is it's too much and
before we continue thank you to
curiosity stream for sponsoring this
episodes the ground for details later
this episode on the how you can get your
first 30 days of this amazing streaming
service for free ok recently on reddit
user Jacob wall face theorized that Fury
has been replaced by Talos as far back
as Captain America the Winter Soldier
and that Nick Fury's cameos in age of
Ultron agents of shields infinity war
and endgame like far from home were all
Skrull fury it's an interesting theory
because yes there are some
inconsistencies with Fury's past
behavior that I had pointed out in past
episodes of this show like in Captain
Marvel a major plot point centered
around the fact that no one ever calls
fury Nick yet in the infinity war
post-credits scene Maria hill referred
to him as Nick three times also pointed
to fury telling Carol Danvers that he
never eats toast when it's sliced
diagonally but some have wanted out this
one scene in age of Ultron where he does
slice bread but I have to say folks no
matter how many times these online
Gunter's claim it to be true fury does
not cut that bread diagonally look at
the slice closely there are clearly four
corners four sides you cut it into
rectangles also it's bread not toast
just please stop quoting that stupid
BuzzFeed blogger whoever said that first
trust the guy who spends every waking
hour staring at frames of more
films it's not diagonal I do love that
reddit theory though the problem is it
has been partially refuted by spider-man
far from home director John Watts who
confirmed that the Nick Fury we saw at
Tony Stark's be an early end of Avengers
endgame was the real Nick Fury not
towers he said I think it's the real
Nick Fury at the funeral and I think
Talos got a debrief from Nick Fury about
this the last time they saw each other
so this tells us that Fury post-2014
could not have been exclusively Talos
but I do believe that after Winter
Soldier many of the times we've seen
fury we've actually been seeing scroll
fury let's start with the Winter Soldier
in this film Fury fakes his own death
after being shot several times in
life-threatening spots across his body
miraculously he survives something that
he probably should not have been able to
pull off and really what have benefited
from having a second version of him to
step in but the ending of Winter Soldier
is thematically significant for Fury's
character he torches this eyepatch he
goes off the grid he says he's headed to
Europe he actually looks over his own
fake grave with an awesome Pulp Fiction
reference on it and he tells Sam and cap
do you better even ask for me tell them
they can find me yeah I think that
theory is the real guy it would just be
really weird that was Talos
impersonating Fury for all these big
character moments but I will say I'm not
convinced that he actually went to
Europe I don't care what the prelude
comics suggest Nick Fury's shield
security apparatus on earth has
collapsed
other than the Avengers there's no one
on this planet that he could trust and
that is why I believe Fury's next move
was to go off world I'll explain how
that works but first thank you to our
sponsor curiosity stream for helping us
make this episode curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals I've really enjoyed
watching dream the future narrated by
Ellen Ripley herself Sigourney Weaver on
curiosity stream and the short film the
science of deception it's given me all
kinds of ideas and how to deceive
YouTube commenters and alike anymore I
got my own little total conspiracy going
on here
curiosity stream is available worldwide
on tons of platforms like Apple TV Roku
Amazon fire and their web app get
unlimited access starting at just $2.99
a month or $19.99 a year and for our
audience the first 30 days are
completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream calm
slash new rockstars and use the promo
code
new rock stars okay back to fury in
space I believe that after shield
collapse in 2014
fury worked with his scroll contacts who
build a new security force a Space
Command spinoff of shield from the
Marvel comics known as sword with its
Space Station headquarters known as the
peak I think that is where Fury is and
the far from home post credit scene and
I think that is why earlier in that film
Talos and Sauron discuss Kree sleeper
cells
I thought Kree having sleeper cells was
top-secret information again Nick what
does this mean for the fury we've seen
in the years since 2014
well the Fury in Avengers age of Ultron
definitely seems a bit out of character
I'm not talking about the bread thing
which isn't a thing stop trying to make
it happen but wince cold it's dark in
the barn about building Ultron theory
says artificial intelligence you never
even hesitated Yuri talks as if he has a
lot of experience with a I turn on
humanity now it could be referring to
Arnim Zola that ghosts in the machine
but I don't know if that was a fully
artificial intelligence the way Ultron
or Jarvis were you could make the case
that this could be Talos referring to
the Kree supreme intelligence which was
a true AI involved in some very sinister
manipulations when giving his
motivational speech to the Avengers in
hawkeye's farmhouse fury says here we
all are back on earth so why would
theory say back on earth none of the
people in this room had left the planet
at this point
aside from Stark I suppose throwing the
nuke through the wormhole in the first
Avengers but really that was just for a
few seconds
Thor of course comes from another planet
but he was on his own side quest in this
moment in age of Ultron to me fury
saying back on earth reminds me a lot of
that big telescope in early on and far
from home
mr. bet is from Earth just not yours
yours was changed from ours in the far
from home trailer a hint that this fury
isn't from earth and I believe neither
is the GAVI extraterrestrial in the
Clint's farmhouse later on an age of
Ultron fury and he'll appear on a
Helicarrier to help rescue the secona
it's nice right
pulled her out of mothballs with a
couple of old friends presumably fury
had some old spy contacts that allowed
him to hijack an old shield Helicarrier
and storage but I doubted the government
or the still Hydra influence shield
remnants would make that hijacking that
easy maybe Fury's friends are the
scrolls who could have helped him hide
an extra Helicarrier we know that their
space shuttles have cloaking technology
as does the Helicarrier which could have
stayed in Earth's orbit they could have
kept it specifically for rescue
operations like this one as refugees
themselves the scrolls would consider
that a top priority this humanitarian
agenda was specifically called out in
the scene this is shield this is what
shields supposed so I think we might be
looking at scroll fury in age of Ultron
I think the same could be true for the
fury who saved bits and Simmons and
agents of shield and of course the fury
that we saw in the infinity war
post-credit scene again Maria Hill calls
him Nick three times and they're driving
just as Fury and he'll we're rolling
around in a black SUV and far from home
Talos and Sauron just love driving he'll
mentions that they're monitoring
satellites and fury mentions contacting
Klein at control I think they both could
be referring to their scroll command
center in Earth's orbit on the peak that
would make it tell us and Sauron who
dusted away at the end of infinity war
who knows what happened to the real fury
in Hill but five years later I believe
the fury at Tony Stark's funeral is the
real fury as what's confirmed like
everyone president this funeral is there
for their own personal attachment at
Tony Taylor's wouldn't need to pose as
fury here just for appearances sake but
I do believe that fury attended this
funeral and it was here that he received
Tony's eat it glasses but he shortly
after return to space had Tails resumed
his post and passed the glasses on to
Peter Parker
the latest switcheroo in this ongoing
Olsen twin style bonk on between two
Fury's allowing him to keep Bo's
something he can only do if he is
willing to coordinate eight
do you think the Nick Fury and age of
Ultron infinity war was actually the
scroll Talos comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at a boss and subscribe the new
rock stars as we seek to uncover every
total conspiracy thank you for joining
me and dug up Fury's grave like what if
the real Fury's hiding in there I told
you you could find me right here
[Music]